TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
BUT THERE WERE -- A LOT OF THEM
WERE WEARING 45 PARAPHERNALIA.
OKAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, LINDSEY GRAHAM
DOWNPLAYING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S RACIST RHETORIC.
THE KIND OF HATE THAT H
ASIAN-AMERICANS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY TERRIFIED THAT THEY WILL
BE VICTIMS OF THE NEXT EXPLOSION
OF VIOLENCE.
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK TRUMP
AND OTHER REPUBLICANS' RHETORIC
CALLING THE CORONAVIRUS THE KUNG
FLU AND CHINA VIRUS CONTRIBUTED
TO THIS RISE IN HATE CRIMES
AGAINST ASIAN-AMERICANS?
>> THE SPANISH FLU.
I DON'T -- IT CAME FROM CHINA.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
THE BIGGEST-OPPRESSED GROUP IN
CHINA ARE CHINESE.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY ARE
HORRIBLE TO THEIR OWN CITIZENS.
THEY DENY THEM THE BASIC
FREEDOMS, AND RIGHTS THAT WE
TAKE FOR GRANTED.
SO, THE FACT THAT THE -- THE
FLU -- THE -- EXCUSE ME,
COVID-19, CAME FROM CHINA IS
JUST A FACT.
AND I DON'T -- I DON'T BUY THAT.
>> WHAT?
YEAH.
I KNOW.
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE THINKING.
I'M THINKING THE SAME THING.
LIKE, WHAT?
WHAT IS -- WHAT DOES THAT HAVE
TO DO WITH ANYTHING?
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT HE WON'T
MAKE AN EXCUSE FOR?
HIM AND OTHERS.
FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
SO, LOOK.
WE ALL HEARD WHAT THEN-PRESIDENT
SAID.
HE SAID IT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AND OVER.
AND I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE.
WE KNOW WHERE THE HATE COMES
FROM.
>> AT THAT TIME, WE CALLED IT
THE WUHAN VIRUS, RIGHT?
WUHAN.
>> CHINA'S COVERUP OF THE WUHAN
VIRUS ALLOWED THE DISEASE TO
SPREAD ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> I CAN NAME KUNG FLU.
I CAN NAME 19-DIFFERENT VERSIONS
OF NAMES.
>> KUNG FLU.
YEAH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> OURSELVES LIKE -- SEE, I LIKE
THE CHINA VIRUS.
OR I LIKE THE PLAGUE FROM CHINA.
>> IT'S GOT ABOUT 24 NAMES.
I CAN CALL IT, FROM COVID, TO
CHINA VIRUS.
I CAN CALL IT THE PLAGUE.
I CALL IT THE CHINA PLAGUE.
>> WE, AND THE WHOLE WORLD, GOT
HIT WITH THE CHINA VIRUS.
THE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES, WHO SUFFERED SO
GRAVELY FROM THE CHINA VIRUS.
IT'S A HORRIBLE THING, THAT WAS
PUT ON TO THE WORLD.
>> DON'T MISS THAT HATE AND
TOXICITY, DO YA?
NOT AT ALL.
LET'S BE HONEST.
WE KNOW WHERE THE HATE COMES
FROM.
AND WE KNOW WHAT IT DOES TO
ASIAN-AMERICANS, ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE,
TONIGHT.
TWO DAYS AFTER THE SECOND
DEADLY-MASS SHOOTING, IN A WEEK.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT?
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO STOP MAKING
EXCUSES?
ESPECIALLY, FOR THOSE WH